it's the first thing I hear always is oh
but Thomas it was cheaper to build in
the past it wasn't it was really
expensive to build buildings in the past
but we thought it
mattered and it's it's a bit like Fast
fashion we discovered cheap we invented
that you could build even cheaper we've
got this fast
architecture that we throw away after 40
years think of what a Victorian engineer
would think if they ared now they would
look up at the satellites and go wow
what did you do amazing they would look
at the mobile phone technology and say
that's incredible they' see an airplane
they would see that and say that's
that's so impressive and then they would
look at the buildings and just say what
happened what you know what were you
thinking and and we mustn't forget
society's richer than ever something
weird happened and we're stuck we're
like stuck in a bunker